born into a blessing and a curse the
trappings of royal privilege come with
the trap of the spotlight from this
moment Harry's life has been watched and
judged and he's never felt the media
play fair I mean you're always there
when he went to school with his mother
there was a famous picture many many
years ago and Harry was very small
sticking his tongue out and his mother
had moreish him for that reason he stuck
his tongue out the media with the other
side of the road sticking their tongue
out at him in order to get a reaction
and he's grown up with a media they've
always been there photographers have
always been there and with what happened
to his mother in 1997 he sort of done a
complete turn and blames the media for
what happened to her the two brothers
have shouldered grief together and the
burden of royal duty the siblings were a
double act
Harry's decision to break free to live
at least in part abroad is momentous
unsettling but at least in part a
product of royal destiny the boy who
would not be king had more freedom than
his bride freedom to make mistakes be
seen drunk get in a tussle with a
photographer but also to strike out and
pursue a military career that rounded
him with a glimpse of life outside the
bubble it didn't change his views on the
media everyone's guilty for buying the
newspapers I guess but hopefully no one
actually believes what they read I
certainly don't but yeah of course of
course I really if there's a story and
something written about me I want to
know and what's being said but all it
does is just upset me and anger me that
people can get away with writing the
stuff they do he was sometimes playful
with the press pack but often abrupt and
suspicious important future come here
and talk to them
love and marriage would only enforce his
mistrust you cannot always have positive
coverage and I think that there has been
some justified criticism in the press
particularly in the British press you
know the obvious example is Prince Harry
and Mick and Mark all being these
eco-warriors and preaching about climate
change and then jumping on and off
private jets that doesn't sit well with
the British public and that's the sort
of behaviour that the British press is
going to hold them to task over the
Sussex a--'s new website explains
they're revising their approach to media
withdrawing from dealing with royal
correspondence but can they achieve this
and still perform any royal duties just
one of many outstanding questions where
is the balance for them when it comes to
performing this public role and also
having a life outside of that this could
be a blueprint for future generations as
we look to a new era potentially with a
more streamlined monarchy perhaps
princess hala Prince Larry this is a
model that they could adopt which is
another reason why it's really important
for them to get this right son of the
people's princess will he become the
Instagram Prince he wants to focus on
his new family but to maintain any
public role within the royal family the
arrangement has to be one that the
British public can accept Jason Farrell
Sky News